.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une école québécoise
Des élèves allumés,
mais aussi agités.
♪ ♪ ♪
des cinq principaux partispolits
la classe de Madame Geneviève.
- Allô!
- L'école primaire
les Explorateurs, à Laval,
est publique, multiethnique.
Elle est aussi vétuste comme
plus d'une école sau Québec. Le,
la bibliothèque, les toile les s
sont condamnés le temps de faire
des travaux. Ici les classesress
en plus d'élèves présentant
des défis particuliers.
- Le but, cet après-midi, élèveà
définir quatre caractéristiq
de la phrase de base.
- La classe de 6e annéee Genevié
sera notre laboratoire.
L'enseignante a assigné
une matière à chaque candidat.
tout ça?
st parti... ou presque.
- Tu veux remplir ta bouteille?
Vas au bout de ton projet.pouves
asseoir?
- Pas la même chaise quand même!
- Je peux aller aux toilettes?
aux toilettes, je laisse aller,
il faut qu'il revienne.
- OK, je peux boire de l'eau.
Est-ce que je peux aller
remplir ma bouteilrais que toute
écrive les réponses sur
sa feuille.
- Il faut enseigner la matière
en moinspas parce qu'on a
déjà été sur les bancs
d'école et qu'on a déjà appris
cette matière-là, que c'est
nécessaila transmettre.
- Il faut aussi assurer
un bon climat.
- Pendant que j'avais mon trio
de l'autre mon trio de garçons
qui s'accusaient de tricher
en même temps. Il faut que
j'aille calmer le jeu avant
- Chaque candidat représente
une équipe politique qui a
sa vision des choses pour
améliorer le système
Un système inéquitable,
selon le Conseil s
de l'éducation parce qu'il
existe de plusieurs vitesses.
- Ça, c'est l'éternel débat
privé-public.
- On veut mettre fin au système
à trois vitesses.vois pas trop
l'inégalité.
- Je pense pas qu'il faut
s'attaquer au réseau privé.
- On veuivement au financement
public des écoles
- Voyons voir :
veut renforcer le privé.
La Coalir Québec
propose de solidifier
les écoles publiques.
promet d'abolir la plupart
s au public en
conservant le privé.
Le Parti
à un seul système public fort
implantément après
consultation.
Québec
un seul système public fort
andat.--------------------------
cinq vis
♪ ♪ ♪
Retour en classe... Idéalement,
il faut garder les élèves
éveillés.
Ah oui, ah oui, ah oui!
Même toi qui est mort-vivant!
(cris des élèves)s'asseoir.
- C'est le temps de leur
- Moi, je suis avec le Parti
du Québec.
- En vue de l'élection
- Vous avez des questions?
- Si jamst élue quelle
est la première chose que vous
allez changer en l'éducation
- J'aimerais vraiment
oir des
enseignants dans les classes.
- Travailler à la pénurie s.
- De donner davantage deressour.
- Je vais m'assurer, quand vous
allez à l'école, soit bon.soit .
- C'est permettre aux gens qui
aident les élèves en difficultér
être capable d'aider les élèves
partout au Québec.
- Si vous êtes élu, commentainse
vos promesses seront réalisées?
- Quand les élus font
des promesses et quila populatin
a le droit de les chicaner.
- Moi j'aime mieux dire que
c'est des engagements plutô
- J'ai un devoir de réussiret d.
- Il faut faire confiance
aux gens qu'on éluêtre certêtre.
L'important c'estl'imputabilité.
- Au-delà des promesses
aussi des enseignants quimarque.
- Bien, moi, je levraiment allus
levaientent
participer.
- Moi jeimard,
un prof exceptionnel.
Quand je l'ai vu aimer
sa matière, mais surtout aimer
.
- J'ai un prof au cégep qui
nous a dit que les 1 % des plus
riches de la planète détenaient
donnée-là m'avait tellement
choquée.
- On y pense pas assez souvent
comment c'est un espace
On ne sait pas ce qu'ils vivent
à l'extérieur.
- Ma gra
déficience intellectuelle.
son quatrième enfant et àt-là, ,
mon enseignante de maternelle
cinq ans, bien, else
mentale à ma mère, pour nousfais
rendre à l'école.
- Des candidats qu
particulièrement ceux ayantdes e
une priorité pour le prochain
gouverne,
Radio-Canada, Lav